la québécoise stéphanie hervé s'est
taillé une place au sein des vedettes
des jeux vidéo
plusieurs fois championne du monde elle
prend maintenant ses distances avec la
compétition stéphane et hervé
ta première fois que tu deviennes
ketchup la championne du monde jeux
vidéo cette loi est vraiment et pas
n'importe qui dans cet univers lost
univers justement les gens connaissent
peut être un peu moins par mois tombant
de ton univers de ce que tu fais depuis
tant d'années mais ma passion c'est le
jeu vidéo
puis c'est vraiment facile de comprendre
si on fait juste le parallèle avec
n'importe quelle autre activité que ça
soit grand musicien ou un grand sportif
et ma vie est vraiment axé sur mes
performances en jeux vidéo et elle
accorde donc vivante l'incarnation du
fait qu' on peut passer des heures et
des heures et des heures des jours des
mois des semaines des années à devant
des écrans à jouer des jeux vidéo puis
bien s'en sortir parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de mythes peut-être je sais pas à
déconstruire à propos des jeux vidéo
il ya énormément je pense qu'en général
et encore un style moins négatif une
espèce de nuages noirs par rapport aux
jeux vidéo
un peu comme on voyait le rock n roll ou
les films il ya très très longtemps
malheureusement à cause qu'on a déjà ce
stig moller négatif on pense que et si
notre jeune joue trois quatre heures par
soir à des jeux de voilà il est super
dépendant lui dit d'arrêter il veut
parler voilà il est super départ alors
que c'est peu dire qu'ils sont les
patrons des choses positives
celles qui apparaissent comme étant les
plus évidentes ce que nous en faire un
petit aperçu web elle est plus évidente
c'est sûr que lorsque quelqu'un est
passionné d'un sujet by s'épanouit
il y apprend toutes sortes d'habilité
qu'ils n'auraient pas autrement dans le
jeu vidéo précisément là il ya des
dixièmes dizaines voire centaines
habilité qu'on développe à jouer des
jeux que ça soit des réflexes et les
multi tasking la multi tâches que ça
soit même apprendre l'anglais et même au
niveau de la socialisation
malgré le fait qu'on pense que les jeux
vidéo et thématiques qui renferme c'est
totalement faux la plupart des jeux
vidéo nous permettent de faire partie
d'une comme de jouer en réseau de juin
reste numéro 2 puis c'est au tour de
exact de faire des amis de possiblement
voyage et d'être quand même différente
culture puis que mes parents stéphanie
qui achètent le mérite mandat qui est
possible à son enfance à payer ou à
l'office
est ce que quelque chose qu'on peut
faire pour que nos enfants et les
meilleures conditions possibles quand on
joue aux jeux vidéo
absolument je pense qu'un des plus
importants qu'on connaît pas du tout jeu
pendant la société en général
c'est vraiment la qualité de l'écran ok
c'est vraiment important de faire
attention à nos yeux sont un très jeune
âge les écrans de base qu'on ne la
plupart sont des écrans à 69 ses écrits
à 60 earth leur font que la sécheresse
visuel est quand même assez importante
parce qu on cligne - des yeux et cite un
écran sans vrt plus le plat augmente et
le nom de clément que tu fais là
naturellement donc ça c'est un
équipement que je suggère aux parents
des mains sûres s'ils veulent
s'impliquer dans la passion de leurs
jeunes c'est des écrans en eau de 100
verte
je sais pas si tout le monde comprend
quel point ces gros tellement que ça
brasse dessoudé à faire un peu partout
dans le monde
il ya des gens qui en vivent bien au
delà de la moyenne jeu des ricains qui
en gagnent plus qui ont donc besoin de
l'argent avec ça qu'est-ce-qui quelle
est la meilleure illustration de la
percée jeu vidéo made man dans
l'économie industrie qui fait qu'ils
génèrent le plus d'argent plus que le
cinéma depuis plusieurs années mais je
dirais que c'est ce que facile à
comprendre c'est surtout le goût du
nombre de spectateurs gros tournois
comme bing
les jeunes du camp d'achraf pour
chercher des millions de personnes dans
le sport il ya que le support bolt peut
vraiment se positionner comparé aux jeux
vidéo tout les reste la coupe stanley
voyez les finales nba
c'est même pas proche d'avoir la même
norme de visibilité qu'elle est juge et
au canada ce qu'on joue beaucoup à des
jeux vidéo aucun des jeux c'est pas ça
surprend on est les plus gros
consommateurs de jeux vidéo monde soit
femme 2%
la population se consola joueurs j'avoue
que ça me surprend plus gros que la
corrida
je me rappelle j'étais en corée du sud 2
pour les jeux olympiques en 2018
c'était dans l'air une épreuve à l'essai
c'est la folie furieuse la fin quand on
joue plus que joue plus que oui on
pourra tourner les plus gros sur la
planète et pour eux c'est leur sport
national faut changer nos lunettes quand
on observe le phénomène d'autant plus
que là il ya une discussion et débat
autour de la possibilité que ça fasse
partie des jeux ea sports est ce que
réellement cela en toile donc assez
s'impose c'est lorsque tu connais du
monde dans lequel on vit est ce que
c'est facilement envisageable
oui j'ai même pas de doute c'est plus
une question de cas et quand est ce que
ça va être
paris 2024 moi j'ai mon karma dick we
put ce qui est déjà qu'ils disputaient
sûrement fait dire aussi par le sport
est-ce qu'on répondra sur qu'est ce que
c'est bon mais moi je trouve que c'est
un non débat parce que on s'en fout si
c'est un sport ou non on n'a pas le
débat sur le billard le curling et parce
que c'est pas seulement pour moi qui est
important ce qui est important c est ce
que c'est une passion pour certains gens
et à ce que les athlètes qui jouent à
des jeux vidéo compétitif jusqu'à mans
sont des hackers et pour moi et ils sont
les uns
[Musique]
oh